mrs. acting 10 o'clock and this is
Curry's digital just up the road from
Clapham Junction for the last three
quarts of an hour kids have been in and
out of this store taking whatever they
want really well it's hard to believe
that it's five years this month since
the riots in London I covered that quite
extensively for Sky News I was in
Clapham that night I lived in Clapham
back then I found myself in a relatively
strange position in that on the one hand
I was a journalist documenting what was
happening in front of me but but also I
was a resident of this area watching the
streets that I shop in daily being
systematically destroyed and I was very
keen to try and understand why people
were doing it what's it now I'm just I
live here I'm just astounded at what
you're doing you're getting your taxes
that what do you mean by that so so by
stealing things are getting a taxi but
are you proud of this are you proud of
what you're doing are you proud of what
you're doing they were having a good
time and that was one thing that was
striking there were some among the
looters and writers who were clearly
very very angry I remember especially
those who love pulling the TV's off the
wall of Ladbrokes they were extremely
angry but but others just seemed to be
having a laugh it was their moment of
anarchy and they were enjoying it you
are you proud of what you're doing
stealing stuff what was that about I
remember after the event David Cameron
the prime minister at the time described
what had happened as criminality pure
and simple but there was clearly a lot
more to it than that yes some of the
young people who were looting were
opportunists they just wanted to get
their hands on a free television and
many many did but the must have been
underlying issues in society that caused
those riots the whole road is a complete
mess strewn with electrical appliances I
suppose the question now is could what
happened then happen again and the
answer has to be yet there is underlying
tension between those who who feel that
they are somewhat affluent and those
that feel that they're left behind and a
significant proportion of those people
rioting that day I think either
consciously or subconsciously felt left
behind